Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dave from is it
heralds Burg.
I can't quite see.
Speaker 5: It's Healdsburg, sir, thank you
so much.
I'm honored to speak to a frickin predator.
Speaker 1: He'll yes, thank you.
He'll hold on.
I have that drop.
That is a frickin predator.
Speaker 5: What is Healdsburg?
Healdsburg is in Sonoma County, just north
of San Francisco.
Oh hi, Miles.
Beautiful area.
Yeah, I'm currently standing in a vineyard,
it's a wonderful life.
Speaker 1: I got to get back.
I've been to a bunch of the vineyards there
and it is just great.
There's this I believe in where I believe
in downtown Napa.
There's like a high end food court called
the Oh man, I don't even remember.
It's just it's just a great area.
Speaker 5: I very much enjoyed myself besides
the chair my whole life, so well, what's on
your mind for a living?
I'm going to talk about Joe Rogan as well.
No offense, no context.
I started with Joe Rogan in episode thirty
six in June of 2010.
I never missed an episode until October 2020,
when I couldn't take it anymore.
The comedy of idiocy and the things that he
was saying about politics in general fashion
on Biden seemingly ignoring all the problems
with Trump, I'm more or less gave it up, but
I've gone back to listening.
When the pandemic is out and I think people
are missing some significant things here,
the audience of Joe Rogan, they don't care
about fact checkers, they don't care what
the mainstream media says.
And the more they attack him, the more they're
going to run to him.
Yes, if he has any chance at cost, of course.
Correction, somebody needs to go on the Rogan
podcast and talk him out of the bad ideas
that he has hung on to.
And I don't know who that person is.
Do you have any ideas?
Speaker 1: No, I don't.
I mean, I don't know that there's any one
person who can talk them out of everything.
I think it's, you know, with Rogan, it's a
lot of he'll he'll listen to anybody he has
on.
The challenge is getting the right people
on, and I'd be glad to be on any time with
him.
I'm not an expert in a lot of the areas in
which he's allowed incorrect information to
fester.
I'm aware of the fact that the information
is wrong, but I'm not an expert in that, but
I don't think there is any one person.
I think it would take sort of like a concerted
effort of bringing on different types of guests
for an extended period of time, quite frankly.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I mean, I think what you
could do is point out to him that he's far
too inclined to accept the person's supposed
qualifications.
I mean, even in his apology.
When it came on the first time, you didn't
see immediately through the qualifications
of Nicola and Malone as well.
That alone makes something that they say is
true.
Yes.
Which is just absolutely wrong.
And then, of course, when it came to the apology
for the N-word video, a previous caller just
got it wrong.
I don't think Spotify took those down.
I think Rogan took them down.
I think he got tired of having those out there
out of thousands of episodes.
What's it matter if there's 110?
It only benefited him as well because now
people think he's under attack and people
are taking as his episodes.
Yeah, I mean,
Speaker 1: the think the statement was that
Spotify has taken them down.
What you're suggesting is that what's been
reported isn't true, which is possible, but
I think it's meant we should be clear that
this is just your opinion.
Speaker 5: Yeah, and that's based on what
he said in his in his apology video for that.
I just think it's it's far more likely that
he did want it out there anymore because he
saw himself in the video and like you said,
it made him sector to his stomach just to
see himself saying those things.
So, yeah, no harm in taking them down.
When there's thousands of episodes, it's not
like anybody was going to listen.
I mean, that's the thing with Michael Malone's
episodes to put fact checks on them.
Take him down.
Censor em, it doesn't matter that information's
already out there.
Yep, at this point, the Rogan mantra of the
only things to do with that speech is to combat
it with good speech is the only strategy that
worked going forward.
I agree somebody has to go on and talk to
him.
Typekit those ideas.
David, I'm a huge fan, have been for a long
time member and it's been an absolute pleasure.
Thank you.
All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Dave.
Appreciate.
Appreciate your your support.
And as a member, Dave gets access to the much
derided bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.